all right guys here it is the most
anticipated camera of 2023 the Nikon Z8
skin softening portrait Impressions all
that great stuff you know if you want to
look five years younger Zaki looks like
he's 15 now it's just a little wrong now
let's try the portrait Impressions three
is a little bit warmer so you see
exactly a little bit more tan out of it
cutting out that sort of that warmth
that yellowish to his toe now I've added
a little more red into that all right so
we're waiting for Zaki to get all suited
up here kind of Parts
Ava hey Tom Cruise soon a little bit
[Music]
stunt work
he takes the motorcycle real nice
[Music]
things we do for what guys don't forget
to like And subscribe okay